you hear sometimes about you know
different celebrities coming out with
their brand of like us you know a
special liqueur or spirit huh and you
did something with Bryan Cranston and
the fact that the two of you are doing
it together yeah sounds really
intriguing it's mezcal right let's go
yeah you know he's one of my best my
best friends my mentor and we were
having sushi one night in New York and
he said is it too early for us to do
maybe a another project it's a show or a
film maybe a play and I said I think it
is too soon this is way before the
conversation of alchemy no way before we
were having that conversation anyways
I go we could go into business together
and he said what sort of business and I
said why don't we go under the booze
business and he just laughed at me and I
got him being serious what do you think
about mezcal and he's like the thing
with the worm at the bottom of it like
no though it doesn't have to be like
that and then we ordered a couple mescal
drinks and that's when the seed was
planted and then we just couldn't stop
talking about it it's been a little over
three years but we just launched this
year okay and this is called what the
name of it is dos hombres dos hombres
and we have a bar looking at the I
always keep alcohol back here and E gets
he gets the shakes I'm constantly okay
it's coming it's coming we're gonna get
a break but I love this logo you've got
to I love that logo two donkeys what was
that all about
we just love donkeys we consider
ourselves to two donkeys just trying to
make it happen
traditional way of making mess cow one
of the ways to smash up the agave is a
donkey
wheeling pulling a giant concrete or
stone wheel and walking it around and
just smashing up the agave and so we
wanted to use use two donkeys and then
and you look really hard to find this we
did we traveled out
Oaxaca multiple times and our main thing
is look look if we can't find the
perfect juste and there's no reason for
us to do it it has to be really really
say I love you and Brian wandering
around Mexico looking for a
mind-altering substance can someone help
us please that you want to market all
right we have some Glau my god okay what
what is is this this is already this is
pre-board right oh nice that smells
really good actually I will say that
right now mezcal is a very smoky flavor
I love that smokiness is it nice cheers
my friend oh thanks very soon
isn't it nice this show just got so much
cooler I don't know you guys were an
official sponsor I would be drinking
this like Dean Martin every night on the
show I'd be like our next guest yes
plenty more where this came from my
friend I think this is very good this is
and this is just you know just on the
rocks all right this is a healthy pour
though I mean it's 15 minutes before we
drive home
hi they'll make me take that out Turner
Bryan's sending bad messages to young
people 26 years Camino a Breaking Bad
movie a Breaking Bad movie is streaming
now on netflix and Aaron you have
another movie out the parts you lose is
now available on video on demand and of
course all digital platforms thrilled to
have you back you are welcome here
anytime that you bring such good boost